brain hub is an initiative that brings
together people across campus from
disciplines as diverse as engineering
and statistics to biology and psychology
and it's really focused on how we can
understand brain function at multiple
levels from the level of synapses the
connections between cells to the Colet
large collections of neurons that behave
in developing Mergent properties that
you couldn't predict by studying one
molecule or one connection my current
research involves investigating cellular
ensembles that are engaged by sensory
experience and we're particularly
interested in somatic sensation because
there's a very clear map for how sensory
input drive cells in the in the cerebral
cortex so there might be 20 different
neuron types in the cerebral cortex we'd
like to be able to genetically label
each one of those and see develop a
complete matrix for how individual types
of cells are talking to each other in
order to do this we're using machine
learning tools we're using molecular
genetic techniques and we're working
with imaging and statistical resources
here at the University and so we're
bringing bringing to bear the really
interesting question of how brain
function changes over time how we learn
how we develop how we age our goal here
is not to fully develop a wiring diagram
of the brain although that certainly
will be useful our goal is to understand
under what conditions those wires are
used and what we're discovering is
they're not used all the time and there
are very specific conditions under which
connect some connections are turned off
or turned on until we understand those
specific conditions we won't understand
what the neural circuits are doing brain
hub is an initiative that brings
together people across campus from
disciplines as diverse as engineering
and statistics to biology and psychology
and it's this multidisciplinary effort
that I think it's really going to enable
us to make enormous progress in this
area
you